at BWW the future has begun the new I
ate is a plug-in hybrid sports car with
innovative design and technology the
specie ecological sportster looks as if
it came from another planet or at least
another century back to the future sums
it up when you see the new Beemer a
many-faceted attention getter
yeah obviously our current Chester I
know Dyson over says BMW regards the i8
as the future of the sports car it has
both an electric and an internal
combustion engine let's see what this
car can do interplanetary mission
accomplished that might be a good slogan
for the BMW i8 the front is extremely
low and broad the stretch lines the
broad 4.7 meter wheelbase and the flat
silhouette give the car a very dynamic
appearance the rear is an eye catcher
and its wings shaped taillights are
futuristic without looking at a place
the scissor doors set an optical
highlight and fit perfectly in the
overall appearance LED lamps front and
back are standard equipment
the I aids battery can be charged from
any outlet plugged into a wall box it's
charged in under two hours by the octave
final Dyson / explains that to
compensate for the two hundred kilogram
electric drive the chassis is made of
lightweight carbon fiber and you can see
that for example on the undersides of
the scissor doors the workmanship is
flawless and the car handles well like a
typical BMW the exterior sportiness
extends seamlessly to the interior the
design shows new forms and lines without
neglecting typical BMW components the
colors and materials support the theme
of a smart sustainable sports car
ecological soundness is seen in the use
of light plastics made from recycled
soft drink bottles
and the BMW eDrive technology an
innovative cooling system keeps the high
voltage battery at optimal temperature
at all times that enhances power and
extends the life of the system
intelligent energy management
coordinates the interaction of the
electric engine battery and internal
combustion engine
damn once the BMW's I a project manager
constant I'd felt says the company
wanted to build a sports car for the
21st century that combined the reduced
emissions of an electric car and the
emotional appeal of a sports car the
challenge was to do it in one vehicle
concept item fought such concepts of
incidents BMW cut its standard
six-cylinder engine in half inserted it
sideways in the i8 and gave it a
turbocharger and an electric motor as
companions thanks to the lightweight
carbon fiber chassis the result is a
plug-in sports car weighing only 1400 90
kilograms yeah our car tester says the
i8 is a real Road hugger a very low set
battery in the middle of the car means a
low center of gravity and good handling
the i8 has several suspension modes in e
drive mode the electric motor provides a
top speed of 120 kilometers an hour and
a range of 35 kilometers in comfort mode
the electric engine runs alone up to 65
kilometers an hour and then the internal
combustion engine kicks in in sports
mode the gasoline-powered engine takes
the lead but if more acceleration is
needed the electric engine pitches into
da by nakta electro motor this king of
cool is an aggressive sports car but not
over-the-top it has 266 kilowatts of
power a top speed of 250 kilometers an
hour and leaves from 0 to 100 kilometers
an hour in 4.4 seconds specs that are
all quite sporty but the manufacturer
says it consumes just 2.1 liters of fuel
per 100 kilometers which means co2
emissions of just 49 grams per kilometer
the i8 will come on to the German market
in early June at a price of one hundred
twenty six thousand euros BMW expects
the card is sell well in the United
States especially in California
I know Dyson / says the i8 may well
represent the future of the sports car
it consumes only half the fuel its
rivals do and its design as the future
on its side Dyson HOFers only criticism
is that you have to be a bit sporty
yourself to get in and out of the car if
you want to wield the power of the
future but experience it in the present
start saving your pennies
and Volkswagens latest contribution to
the supermini segment is now not this
one it's this the fifth generation of a
long-standing classic and it's had a
facelift the auto car Chester Klaus
needs fits realizes most people are well
acquainted with a Volkswagen Polo after
all 14 million of them have been sold
since 1975 and seven hundred twenty
thousand and two thousand thirteen alone
that makes the Polo one of the world's
most popular subcompact cars now he's
going to show what it's got and what it
can do on a spin around Lake Tegan's a
the new polo looks typically VW plane
and straightforward a new chrome strip
under the grill makes for a more
distinctive look the rear of the new
polo also leaves a dignified impression
bisex our expert points out that VW
offers six engines for its new polo
diesel and gasoline powered versions
ranging between 1-liter 3-cylinder units
and 1.4 liter units this one is a TDI
diesel that generates 66 kilowatts at a
top speed of 180 km/h BW rates the fuel
consumption of three point four liters
per hundred kilometers postman is 3.7
but he was driving fast either way not
bad the TDI and it's blue motion
technology promised both fuel efficiency
and fun 66 kilowatts are enough for
decent pick up and 88 grams of co2 per
kilometer earned the Polo a grade a plus
for ecology but starting at almost
eighteen thousand euros the diesel costs
a chunk more change than the base model
then again it's the best performance
with the lowest consumption
the handling makes it fun to drive in
terms of both agility and comfort the
polo can hold its own on country roads
as well
it's on father roast meats fits thinks
vw's made quite some progress on the
chassis and the overall manageability
the polo takes curves quite nicely and
safely the suspension can be set to one
of three modes sport normal or comfort
unlike with certain other cars the
difference is actually noticeable that's
it what does is not the sport select
suspension is available for an extra 380
euros typically for the Polo it's highly
responsive steering suits it ideally two
cities full of narrow streets and Alex
another many of the electronic safety
features are making their debut in this
class the post collision braking system
is standard while City emergency braking
the driver alert system and a rear view
camera are all optional equipment the
new polos interior is as solid as ever a
feature taken from the VW Golf is the
new navigation system
by the test funds after his test drive
Klaus is surprised by the new suspension
system its handling performance
equipment and design he's decided it's
one of the great super minis the base
model starts at twelve thousand four
hundred fifty euros with a 45 kilowatt
gasoline engine that's not enough power
for him 66 kilowatts are the much better
choice for driving a car full of people
on the Autobahn oi cas valiante inside
the polo has come a long way in nearly
30 years as can be seen by the new
version the standard and optional
assists are sending a new benchmark for
the segment
prezzo has launched a hatchback version
of a 308 wagon to complement the
second-generation sedan the 308 SW has
an 11 centimeter longer wheelbase and an
extra twenty two centimeters at the rear
in addition to a fish in new engines the
new model also boasts a rework design
the interior is a no frills affair with
an uncluttered dashboard and controls
watch out for Hyundai's new grand Santa
Fe it's 23 centimeters longer than the
regular Santa Fe which is manifests in
more legroom and cargo capacity the
standard grand Santa Fe has a six seed
configuration with two single seats at
the back buyers can alternatively order
the seven-seat version at no extra
charge with a three-person bench in the
second row
in his PT is engulfing Berg to get hands
on a rather hands-free experience with
autonomous driving although we do have a
human driver on board too much on board
so I may ask I have a driver's license
why I'm not allowed to drive a car yes
this is an early prototype of our
autonomous vehicle and the system is not
complete yet so I still have to
supervise the system and I still have to
take care of some scenarios by myself
but it will give you a preview of the
future of commuting at first glance this
looks like any other volvo s60 in fact
it's fitted with radar sensors a front
view camera and gps let's see how it
copes with traffic and gothenburg on the
beltway and leia shows us how the car
drives itself on certain sections
I will activate the system now so I just
push this button so now I can glow my
hands and it's system will adapt to the
traffic in front it will reduce the
speed when necessary and it will follow
the name I have removed by feet from the
pedals so it handled acceleration and
brakes and also the steering by itself
autonomous driving is gaining traction
in the automotive world and vulval is
not the only car maker researching the
possibilities what makes the drive me
scheme and Sweden special is that it
boasts an all-round package it's a joint
initiative hooking up Volvo's technology
with a city of Gothenburg swallows
government agencies
we offer the space of the city so that
they the cars have somewhere to to to
drive so we are going to use the
ordinary roads around the city of
gothenburg so that's our input to the
project but also we we are very keen on
seeing the results and see how we can
integrate this in City Planning traffic
on the Ring Road can get really heavy
during rush hour exactly the right
environment for an autonomous car it
allows the driver to sit back and relax
and devote that time to other activities
it also allows present infrastructure to
be used more efficiently autonomous cars
are able to drive at a short distance to
each other in addition to freeing up
traffic space that saves fuel by
profiting from the preceding vehicle
slipstream expect the infrastructure to
be more compact and that we can use land
in a better way that the lanes may be an
error and
that we can avoid congestion in a far
better way than today and of course that
we expect also with autonomous driving
fully implemented that we have almost
zero accidents and incidents which we
also contribute to a sustainable future
the car does not yet have sensors to
perform a 360 degree scan so for now the
driver has to do the lane changing when
parking however the driver doesn't even
need to be in the car at all this is a
task the cars can do completely
independently
autonomous driving opens up new
opportunities on the stationary traffic
front self parking cars will mean more
efficient use of parking garages and
less frustration for drivers
a look ahead to the future instead of
endless circles in the garage next to
the mall shoppers can drop their car off
at the entrance and then use their phone
to activate autonomous parking the
vehicle sets up and uses sensors to
localize and navigate itself to a free
space
once the driver is done shopping he
pushes a button on a cell phone that
tells the car to return to the drop zone
and the scenario it's the car that picks
up the driver
autonomic fan with indecision s
development will make driving safer but
as it ultimately depends on the driver
there is an attention sensor it monitors
the movement of the driver's eyes even
if you're wearing glasses das Auto fest
and I found the driver is unable to
retake control because they've fallen
asleep or is unwell the car will engage
certain measures to alert them that
might be a pull on the belt or shaking
the seat that the driver fails to
respond the car will exit traffic and
perk itself but also to awesome freeze
nunchaku callsign and destinations just
uncommon the attention sensor is one of
a number of pre-existing assists that
Volvo has taken to the next level
instead of investing in complex and
completely new technologies it's that
approach that the car maker hopes will
help keep the concept at a reasonable
cost for consumers
the aim is very clear our society is
changing our needs are changing the
needs for the transportation system are
changing this is what we are here to
make this revolution to give people back
their time and do this in a safe manner
and also thinking about the environment
it's important that the package is
affordable otherwise we cannot make any
impact on the society we cannot give you
our customers the benefit Volvo is also
thinking of its own future too of course
future cars catering to future needs are
bound to sell well but then there are
the legal complexities who is liable of
an autonomous car has an accident
it's a challenge but if we want
development we have to see that our
legislation is following the development
in society and loss has been changed
before so there is no loss who who are
written in in stone you have to change
laws when the development takes place
but of course you have to guarantee the
safety as well 2017 will be crunched and
hopefully not crash time for oval the
drive me scheme envisages letting loose
a hundred cars on selected streets in
and around gothenburg by then the
autonomous fleet will explore the social
and technical challenges involved in
hands-free driving the next step in the
evolution of the driverless car
yes this really is the latest Seattle
Tia XL it seems a little like a dinosaur
among the sleek new models from Seattle
but looks aren't everything 4 2015 seeit
has enhanced the compact MPV with new
technology will test the version with a
for you equipment package which includes
some extras for additional comfort but
also our current history Manuel Schafer
says the altea XL exterior hasn't
changed much since 2009 it doesn't speak
the design language of all the new see
odd models and so it seems a bit
old-fashioned car buyers are indeed used
to a different more angular design these
days the altea is more rounded with
sporty details if that's what you like
the XL could be for you and this model
XL stands for the size and the 44 the
four-wheel drive which helps you tackle
tough terrain
difference c'mon oh I was testing a
2-liter TDI in the four-wheel-drive
version he says the vehicle is suitable
for taking the whole family on a winter
vacation our test car's engine produces
103 kilowatts the 6-speed manual
transmission shifts crisply and top
speed is 198 kilometers an hour
acceleration from 0 to 100 kilometers an
hour takes 10.1 seconds which isn't
exactly blistering but the altea is
still powerful say at says the altea XL
consumes 5.7 liters per 100 kilometers
but we burned a little more fuel during
our test at six and a half liters per
100 kilometers the altea isn't a guzzler
suiting its for long distances but the
driver's seat is a bit hard for a long
drive the El tias interior is simple
which is not necessarily a problem
there's nothing to disturb or distract
the eye
the rear seats can be moved forward or
backward to accommodate more luggage or
longer legs the 532 litre trunk is
generous lengkap emmanuelle says the
steering wheel feels good in your hands
and when sportiness to the whole
interior the dashboard has a nice clear
layout with no unnecessary buttons and
the workmanship seems pretty good so the
Optio XL combines sporty handling with
plenty of practical features that will
appeal to car buyers the version we
tested cost 25 thousand eight hundred 90
euros in Germany a reasonable price for
what's delivered Amano says the altea XL
is suited for anyone who wants to take
the family somewhere but don't want to
do it without a bit of a VaVaVoom by
Disney's physician Boyle
berlin's police heritage collection
highlights a fascinating chapter the
city's turbulent past from the end of
World War two until the fall of the
Berlin Wall of 1989 the city was divided
into a division also reflected by the
east and west police forces former
officers have acquired and restore these
pieces of history on wheels the
collection reflects nearly a hundred
years of police heritage a good way to
keep the vehicles in working order is to
keep them moving this personnel carrier
is a 1955 Mercedes 311 used by the West
Berlin police until the 1970s the truck
engineering of the time was robust and
easy to learn even for today's drivers
this is that Nixon and mas explains that
this is a straight-6 diesel engine
recognizable by the fuel injection
system and the fuel filter the six
cylinders put out 90 horsepower
lunch-ish piss the interior is purely
utilitarian the fuel tank inlet is
hidden under the passenger seat the
collection has two MW 240 dash tues the
successor the BMW 326 they were built in
Eisenach east germany in 1954 the
6-cylinder almost 2 litre engine made 57
horsepower former eisenach police
officers keep the village east german
police vehicle ruling so that it gathers
no moss
the police heritage collections VW bug
patrol car is still in street cruising
condition when the shorts patmos boast
that the 68 bug is the pride of the
collection it was the last VW Bug to be
acquired by the West Berlin police and
it was in service till the mid-1970s so
y'all might have a teen up on its side
the chase is a police show staple and
real-life criminals do try to get hold
of fast getaway cars thus it when
traction Avant even gained a reputation
as a gangster mobile its engine wasn't
the most powerful but its advanced
front-wheel drive gave the traction
Avant downright sensational handling for
the day word quickly got around in
criminal circles
police chase cars of the time often got
left in the dust the Ford eiffels
4-cylinder 1.2 liter engine only managed
37 horsepower the collection acquired
one a few years ago yes thoughts patmos
explains that the police cars of the
1920s 30s and on into the 50s generally
did not have revolving blue or red
lights like we know today this signaling
device was an ordinary searchlight with
a blue filter on it son disease naalai
nourished on vine against nirmala Zouche
I involve a bit Ida blonde child the
retired police officers play cops and
robbers in their vintage patrol cars
complete with blue lights and old-school
sirens just to recreate a bit of
automotive history